[Musique]
info intox et la rubrique quotidienne
d'antoine fenaux bonjour antoine bonjour
raphaël les directions l'ukraine se sent
au sang chaud reprises à la machine de
désinformation russe tourne à plein
régime oui absolument raphaël et les
séparatistes notamment pro russes
multiplient les manipulations basé sur
de fausses opérations soit disant menées
par l'armée il craignait ce soir on va
s'intéresser un événement particulier
que j'ai choisi pour où l'explosion
supposée d'un véhicule sur une autoroute
reliant donniez des cagots love qu'elle
aurait fait trois mots à vous le voyez
une information relayée par ce site
d'information je le précise affiliée à
la république séparatiste de deux nièces
qui le donc qui livre l'information en
bray ville selon lui cette brève de
bombe improvisée a explosé au passage
d'un véhicule les démolisseurs de
l'armée et craignent elles sont accusées
il aurait voulu éliminer un commando
séparatistes la vidéo d'un soi-disant
reporter sur place et publié par ce
conte dit no brain pourquoi je dis
soi-disant reporter parce que cet homme
dean o'brian et présents illégalement
dans les territoires séparatistes
ukrainien depuis des années il est
régulièrement accusé de faire de la
propagande pro kremlin il a donc mis en
ligne cette vidéo
il se présente donc lui comme un
reporter freelance je vous le disais
plusieurs journalistes dont nous avons
analysé cette courte séquence vidéo que
je vous présente ici et il ya plusieurs
choses à retenir les isoler la vidéo
pour vous et donc je vais vous montrer
un petit peu ce que ce dont je voulais
vous évoquez voilà tout d'abord le
véhicule en question que l'on voit ici
il est censé donc avoir subi l'explosion
d'un lieu d un engin explosif artisanal
la voiture est bien carbonisé jusqu ici
tout est normal en revanche vous
l'apercevez pro tête elle n'a plus de
vitres et on est par terre il n'y a pas
de débris de verre il n'a pas ça c'est
déjà tout blanc ensuite la vidéo en
question vous le voyez elle n'a pas de
plaque d'immatriculation ni à l'avant ce
nid à l'arrière on le voit plus tard
dans la vidéo mais par commodité je vous
le dis et ça encore c'est un autre
élément qui doit nous mettre la puce à
l'oreille ensuite un autre élément c'est
ce journaliste là encore un soi disant
journalistes patrick lancaster jean ito
proclame autoproclamé relayant cette
information qui lui s'est rendu sur
place ils affirment dans cette petite
séquence que l'on que l'on voit
il pointe on va le voir un petit peu un
petit peu plus loin sur la vidéo si je
me permet d'avancer un petit peu voilà
ici il montre les impacts de balles
soi-disant sur la vidéo et lui la firme
qui est bien ce sont les shrapnel de
l'explosion qui se sont transformés
miraculeusement emballe donc là vous
voyez là encore ça ne colle pas
visiblement on aurait tiré sur le
véhicule après la voix un stand est donc
là encore une fois ça ne ça ne colle pas
et ça c'est assez gros textes car eh
bien déjà rappelé l'enfant de ballet
bien rafale ça n'existe pas une des
vidéos qui est un ensemble a donc
beaucoup à une mise en scène et ça ne
s'arrête pas là oui absolument patrick
lancaster a aussi publié sur son compte
twitter des photos de corps calcinés
présent selon lui dans les véhicules les
images sont assez choquant bien
évidemment j'ai choisi de ne pas vous
les montrer en revanche là encore il ya
plusieurs éléments voilà la publication
en question j'ai choisi une autre vidéo
une autre photo bien évidemment pour ne
pas vous montrer les corses qui en
revanche qui est intéressant et vous
pouvez me croire sur ces corses et
qu'ensuite on voit sur ces corps un
crâne qui est ouvert qui présente une
ouverture très net comme s'il avait été
si est semblable
vraisemblablement à une marque de six
consécutives peut-être à une opération
médico légal en tout cas le corps lui ne
semble pas avoir subi les traumatismes
d'une explosion il est d'ailleurs brûlé
la véhicules autour lui n'est absolument
pas qu'à dessiner des fausses
informations dont qui mettrait en scène
des cadavres le renseignement américain
lui de son côté est bien disait que
c'était très probable que la russie met
en scène ce genre à utiliser ce genre de
méthode s'ils ne l'avaient d'ailleurs
relayé dans un de ses articles
un petit peu un petit peu plus tôt
justement des méthodes très contestable
ans que notre vidéo en question alors
oui alors notre vidéo en question voilà
je voulais elle transpire évidemment
largement la mise en scène au jeu vous
l'art montre dernier exemple que j'ai
choisis pour vous c'est cette petite
camionnette que vous voyez ici voilée
cette camionnette ici raphaël up jeu
mais pose là encore difficile de croire
qu'elle ait subi les marques d'une
explosion vous le voyez les vitres sont
encore présents le véhicule encore une
fois pas de bris de verre à côté pas de
plaque d'immatriculation
là encore et là où c'est intéressant
c'est qu'elle n'est allé brûler
visiblement que d'ailleurs vous
l'apercevez peut-être sur la porte
arrière du véhicule qui avait brûlé de
l'intérieur difficile de croire que
l'epu est touché par un engin explosif
venant de l'extérieur donc là encore la
théorie c'est que ces véhicules auraient
été brûlé brûlé issue d'une casse brûlés
volontairement puis déposé sur place une
mise en scène cynique donc et jeux pour
enfants à prendre un petit peu plus je
vous renvoie vers cet excellent article
publié sur le blog glace nost ghosn qui
est tenu par un britannique qui est très
sérieux et qui a lui mis détaillé point
par point cette fausse opération donc
nouvelle mise en scène y aussi don qui
s'accompagne d'autres infox grossière
autour de cette présence e russe russe
en ukraine nos confrères du site
internet de france 24 ont d'ailleurs
détaillé l'objectif n'est pas de faire
une
faute d un fox crédit mais des deux
noyés dans la masse si vous voulez avec
des infos que ce multiple et l'idée
c'est encore de mettre en place une
sorte de politique du doute c'est à dire
qu'à la fin on ne se rendent pas compte
de ce qui est vrai et de ce qui ne l'est
pas merci antoine fenaux c'était info ou
intox avec antoine rester avec nous on
se retrouve dans trois minutes pour un
nouveau journal dans paris y est